[Music]
the object and the moment of difference
have here lost the meaning of utility
which was the predicate of all real
being consciousness does not begin its
movement in the object as if this were
something alien from which it first had
to return into itself on the contrary
the object is for it consciousness
itself the antithesis consists therefore
solely and the difference between the
individual and the universal
consciousness but the individual
consciousness itself is directly in its
own eyes that which had only the
semblance of an antithesis it is
universal consciousness and will the
beyond of this its actual existence
hovers over the corpse of the vanished
independence of real being or the being
of faith merely as the exhalation of a
stale gas of the vacuous at supremum
paragraph 586 is relatively short and it
there's not that much going on in it but
it's still worth examining because it's
part of this this transition that's
taking place so here he tells us that
the object and the moment of difference
have lost the meaning of utility which
was the predicate of all real being and
we began this section right by talking
about utility wasn't that the great
achievement of the previous section the
truth of enlightenment consisted in
utility what is this telling us there's
going to be something more than merely
utility in the relationship in
consciousness between the object and the
difference this is not going to be the
best way to to conceive of what's going
on and in a way Hegel doesn't actually
have to tell us this because we've
already introduced a really important
idea that of the general will there is a
point to this as we'll see so he says
consciousness does not begin its
movement in the object in the Gagan
stond Kagan is something you know over
and against consciousness consciousness
does not begin its movement in the
object he says as if this were something
alien something foreign from which it
had first to return into itself so then
he says on the contrary
the object is for it consciousness
itself we're now taking consciousness as
the object or you might say we're
bringing the object within the entire
domain of human consciousness now is
this a purely we might say a pistol
illogical move no this is this is really
a matter of practical philosophy we are
bringing whatever object is there within
the scope of our own interests our
desires but those are not simply
particular desires particular interests
because we have the universal
consciousness that what we've been
calling the general
we'll absolute freedom that we have been
discussing so Hegel says we do we have
an antithesis here agin Zots
right there's a little bit of a play on
words here right
the object is gag and Shaitaan that
which is set over against and then the
Gagan Zots
that which is literally said opposites
said to be opposed right
he says the antithesis consists in the
difference between the universal and the
individual consciousness and then he
says but the individual consciousness
itself is directly in its own eyes that
which had only the semblance the shine
in in German the appearance of an
antithesis it is he says universal
consciousness and will what do we have
in mind here the individual
consciousness of the sort that has
actually realized that it is part of
this totality within a society and that
the spiritual masses or spheres within
which it had previously found its place
and its meaning are actually permeated
by the negativity of consciousness so in
a way this antithesis does stand this is
something really to be worked out how do
i as an individual align myself with the
general will how do I discover what the
general will really is so I'm not
mistaking my own desires and biases for
what is really good for the society what
is really willed by the society is there
a thing going in return as the does the
general will oppose me as an individual
in some way only if I resist it only if
I set myself up in opposition to it if I
identify myself with it I am the general
will now eagle ends this by talking
about the beyond of this its actual
existence hovering over the corpse of
the vanished independence of real being
or the being
faith merely as the exhalation of a
stale gas the vacuous at plus-2 Prem
what is he talking about there
well in a way there's a bit of a
digression the ways in which previous
modes of thought have tried to transcend
the social fabric that of culture are
now no longer effective as we've seen
the Atlas opium the great you know the
the Supreme Being doesn't have any
predicates we saw that all the way back
in the struggle of enlightenment with
faith we're now going to essentially
leave that behind
or rather leave it in the background
after the various spiritual spheres in
the restricted life of the individual
have been done away with as well as his
two worlds all that remains therefore is
the imminent movement of universal self
consciousness as a reciprocity of self
consciousness in the form of
universality and of personal
consciousness the universal will goes
into itself and is a single individual
will to which universal law and work
stand opposed but this individual
consciousness is no less directly
conscious of itself as universal will it
is aware that it's object is a law given
by that will and a work accomplished by
it
therefore in passing over into action
and in creating objectivity it is doing
nothing individual but carrying out the
laws and functions of the state
paragraph 587 is very short but very
rich there's a lot going on here well
worth exploring some of which is a
little bit concealed by the translation
inevitably so because some of these
terms are not that easy to surrender
consistently so he begins by saying
after these various spiritual spheres
and the restricted life of the
individual have been done away with as
well as his two worlds and in the German
though word there is elf Haven right
okay boom after the doing away with but
whenever we see that should we just
think about cancellation or should we
think about transcendence with
integration sublation as the the
standard translation used here in
Miller's text so how is this happened by
the individual becoming conscious that
he or she is not just their social class
their status their identity as we might
say in the contemporary sense of
identity politics whether that be
conservative or liberal identity
politics you are not just your
background you are not just your class
your race your gender your pick whatever
you like
you're not just whatever it happens to
be that society has given you and you've
taken on as your role this you know it
could be discovered at a number of
different points in history for Hegel
the the determinative place where this
happens is the lead-up to and during the
French Revolution some people
discovering this and that's part of what
leads to the revolution as they erode
the legitimacy of the the sort of
spiritual spheres and individual
self-interest and others discovering it
as they are revolution
as the conditions of their life reveals
to them new possibilities for
understanding their place within society
so these have been in effect demystified
more thorough understanding of them as
possible
now what are the two worlds before we go
on the two worlds are the real world the
world of work the world of actual doing
and the world of thought the world that
transcends us if we want to go back
earlier the world of culture and then
the world of insight and faith these
worlds have been canceled out as well so
he goes on and he says all that remains
is the imminent movement of universal
self consciousness we're going to see
what that means in a moment the the the
imminent movement so within itself
there's no beyond anymore we don't have
to worry about the vacuous at supreme
that was just talked about and rather
you know silly almost scatological terms
the exhalation of a stale gas right we
don't have to worry about any of that
there's an imminent movement within
society itself of universal self
consciousness figuring out what the hell
it actually is this is a continual
process right what is this imminent
movement of self consciousness Hegel
tells us it's discovering itself as a
reciprocity now the word here that we're
translating as reciprocity which i think
is a perfectly fine translation but it
is a little bit more static it was a
little bit more simply relational than
dynamic the german is vexos vir code
it's a very rich term they're zexal
exchange
vehicle the actual let's call it the
actual doing of exchange or the exchange
if we want to be a little bit you know
silly here and playing around the
exchange of what it is that that one is
is doing the effects the the reality
there is an exchange going on here
within universal self consciousness now
notice that Hegel does not say that it
is an exchange or arrest prosity between
personal consciousness and universal
self consciousness instead it's between
something that is self conscious and
something that we can say may be
conscious or maybe is the static
expression or residue of consciousness
universality in this he says we have a
reciprocity of self consciousness in the
form of universality and personal
consciousness he adds to this the
universal will the universal self
consciousness goes into itself and is a
single individual will a single
individual will the will of me as a
person as Joe Schmoe you know or Jacques
Mata Ross you know the French it's
probably the French Canadian equivalent
of it because I always heard that from
my relatives of you know Joe Blow or Joe
Schmo right there every person who now
realizes that he or she really is a
stand-in for the universal self
consciousness they're not just whatever
they happen to be in their profession or
how they are categorized or anything
like that and they're not just their
individual desires and urges the you
know restricted life of the individual
so he says the single individual will
now what is opposed to that universal
law and universal work
isn't that an interesting idea it's not
just universal law some moral norms that
have to be followed but universal work a
project that your part is not the
totality of if you're a perfectionist
for example it's not going to be very
easy for you to be part of the universal
work now is it because you're always
going to be so busy screwing around with
your own little stuff and never actually
getting it done that the the other
people are waiting on you to finish that
up and you know move on to the next task
so that they can take what you're doing
and make it part of a larger work
hiko goes on and he says this individual
consciousness is no law no less directly
conscious of itself as universal will it
is aware that it's object is a law given
by that will and a work accomplished by
it so he here's where he said something
really interesting
it engages in action and it creates
objectivity it creates objects
it creates we might even say it creates
a new world right he says it's doing
nothing individual but carrying out the
laws and functions of the state is it
doing nothing individual no it is doing
something individual it is exercising
its own will but doing so in a way that
contributes to this universal project
that transcends the previous shapes of
consciousness
this movement is thus the interaction of
consciousness with itself in which it
lets nothing break loose to become a
free object standing over against it it
follows from this that it cannot achieve
anything positive either Universal works
of language or of reality either of laws
and general institutions of conscious
freedom or of Deeds and works of a
freedom that still wills them the work
which conscious freedom might accomplish
would consist in that freedom qui
universal substance making itself into
an object and into an enduring being
this other nurse would be the moment of
difference in it whereby it divided
itself into stable spiritual masses or
spheres and into the members of various
powers these spheres would be partly the
thought things of a power that is
separated into legislative judicial and
executive powers but partly they would
be the real essences we found in the
real world of culture and looking more
closely at the content of universal
action they would be the particular
spheres of labour which would be further
distinguished as more specific estates
or classes universal freedom which would
have separated itself in this way into
its constituent parts and by the very
fact of doing so would have made itself
into an existent substance would
therefore thereby be free from
particular individuality and would
apportion the plurality of individuals
to its various constituent parts this
however would restrict the activity and
the being of the personality to a branch
of the whole to one kind of activity and
being when placed in the element of
being personality would have the
significance of a specific personality
it would cease to be in truth Universal
self-consciousness neither by the mere
idea of obedience to self given laws
which would assign to it only a part of
the whole nor by its being represented
in lawmaking and universal action does
self-consciousness let itself be cheated
out of reality the reality of itself
making the law and accomplishing not a
particular work but the universal work
itself for where the self is merely
represented and is present only as an
idea
there it is not actual where it is
represented by proxy it is not
in paragraph 588 we now arrive at a sort
of impasse in the development of
self-consciousness in relation to the
general will
and so Hegel talks about this this
movement being the interaction of
consciousness with itself in which it
lets nothing break loose to become a
free object standing over against it
keeps everything stuck within the sphere
of consciousness a general universal
consciousness but also an individual
consciousness that identifies itself
with that through its action so notice
what he says next it follows from this
it cannot achieve anything positive
that's a real problem isn't it it cannot
achieve anything positive it cannot
follow through you might say on what
it's supposed to be doing transforming
the social world so what are the things
that it can't actually pull off Hegel
gives us a whole listing of these can it
do universal works of language no at
this point it cannot can engage in
universal works of reality no can't do
that either
how about laws and general institutions
of conscious freedom that sounds really
good but the answer unfortunately is no
what about deeds and works of a freedom
that wills them that wills these laws
and general institutions of conscious
freedom once again the answer is no and
you might say as you should at this
point well that's really strange
you know we freed ourselves of these
these previous things that we're holding
us back these shapes of consciousness
expressing themselves in the
institutions or in social classes we
have this general will and we're
supposed to be doing something through
our action didn't Hegel just say just a
few paragraphs ago that you know
the individual consciousness finds that
its purpose is the general purpose its
language universal law its work the
universal work well what gives that why
can't it actually do anything in this
respect so Hegel tells us and then again
this is remembered just at this point
the work which conscious freedom might
accomplish would consist in that freedom
qua universal substance not qua
individual Kawai universal substance
making itself into an object and thereby
an enduring being how does it do that so
he says this other Nantucket whereby it
divided itself into stable spiritual
masses or spheres and into the members
of various powers so you know it would
once again divide itself functionally
you might say into a number of different
groups institutions communities to which
individuals would then belong and Hegel
talks about a couple different ways that
this might come about he says these
spheres would be partly the thought
things of a power that's separated into
what legislative judicial and executive
powers that is part of what was going on
happened in America would happen in you
know in in France happened in other
places as well this was this is a a well
understood way of breaking apart the
power of government now as Hegel saying
no no no you can't do this because we
need to totalitarian state instead or
something like that no this is just a
temporary setback but to divide itself
into these powers would be to go back to
a kind of you know splitting into
independent or interdependent substances
he says partly these would be
the real essences we found in the the
real world of culture what were these
real essences state power wealth the
noble individual the base individual all
of these sorts of things we'd be going
backwards that's the problem here so he
says looking more closely at the content
of universal action they would be
particulars fears of labor which would
be further distinguished as more
specific estates or classes so we've got
a number of different ways of sort of
dividing up the society and Hegel saying
look at this point consciousness cannot
accept doing that it needs to hold on to
this moment of genuine universality and
that prevents it from engaging in any
genuinely positive work that doesn't
mean that it can't engage in negative
work at this early point tearing down
previous institutions doing what what we
used to call consciousness raising
helping people to realize that they're
not just a member of a particular estate
or class they're not just X Y Z right so
he goes on he says universal freedom
would have separated itself this way
into its constituent parts by the very
fact of doing so it would have made
itself into an existent substance would
thereby be free from particular
individuality what would it do it would
take the plurality of individuals and
now reassign them to its various
constituent parts so this would be a
real problem we want to hold on to this
moment of general will but individuals
not just being parts of a group or
institution or or whatever it happens to
be a function that they're assigned to
but realizing their their alignment with
this general will so he says this would
restrict the activity and the being of
the personality to a branch of the whole
to one kind of activity and being when
placed in the element of being
personality would now have the
significance of a specific personality
here's the clincher it would cease to be
in
Universal self-consciousness this is a a
real dilemma is it not we need to move
past this impasse or else nothing else
can be accomplished how is that going to
happen
well we'll see in the paragraphs to come
but let's let's see what else Hegel has
to say says neither by the mere idea of
obedience to self given laws which would
assign it to it only a part of the whole
nor by its being represented in
lawmaking Universal action does
self-consciousness let itself be cheated
out of reality the reality of itself
making the law and accomplishing not a
particular work but the universal work
itself the people who have become aware
of their their importance as
personalities as individual wills within
the general will are reluctant to give
that up and to go back to just being
represented to being told ok you go back
to the factory now and let the smarter
people handle the politics or whatever
else we want to say along those lines so
he says where the self is merely
represented and as present only as an
idea there it is not actual where it's
represented by proxy it is not now again
this is something that we should
associate with this particular movement
this particular moment in time this this
conception of absolute freedom is this
this practical to live out can you
really have a political system and not
just a political system but a political
system tied to an economic system tied
to a cultural system tied to all these
other things that really gives every
single person their say at every point
and allows them to be entirely
participating no you can't so there is a
problem here a problematic that we're
going to try to work through in the
paragraphs yet to come
you